Julian Brothers Bakery is a community fixture
in this Detroit suburb.
It’s one of the few small, locally run operations
left.
Every morning for the past 48 years, Richard
Julian has put on his apron and served the
neighborhood everything from deli meats to
birthday cakes.
The bakery is also situated on the edge of
a county that was pivotal for Trump’s victory:
Macomb County, outside of Detroit.
Julian, like some of his employees and many
of his customers, voted for Trump.
He thinks the President's term has been good
for his 30 employees, and his bakery.
"Donald Trump was a little much of a stretch
for me in the beginning, but when he became
the nominee of the party, I backed him, because
he was a businessman."
This is exactly the sort of small Middle American
establishment that was at the heart of trump’s
campaign message: to lift up the little guy
and stick it to the "elites."
Ann Celine Wydeven, an educator and neighborhood
resident, said she was attracted to Trump
and his message in part because of how different
he sounded.
"The more I listened, and the more I heard
his concretizing ideas, those were my ideas.
And, that's what I began to watch.
And I was, at first.
In the first debate, I was almost inside the
TV; I thought 'What am I listening to?'
It was just very interesting.
It was so different.
And it wasn't staid.
It was just, different."
They don’t love everything about him: Everyone
we spoke with mentioned that his tweeting
can be cringe-worthy; that maybe he has a
tendency to speak without thinking.
And sometimes his personal life can be messy.
But Joan Fernane, a bakery regular and lifelong
Michigan resident, said despite everything
she wants to see the president succeed.
"I'd like to see him take us back to the days
when people were people, not units or objects
or numbers or classifications.
Where people were people, and we have respect
for one another, and I like some of the things
he's done on the spur of the moment, I just,
I really like the man, and I want to see him
continue with his goals and at least get most
of them accomplished."
Not everybody in the neighborhood is a Trump
supporter, and some family ties have been
strained.
Gary Milburn, an employee at the bakery has
two daughters who do not like Trump.
He says he understood their objections.
But he still voted for Trump.
"My family is not thrilled with me because
you know I did vote for Trump.
You know he's definitely many statements regarding
grabbing women by the whatever, and doing
this and that, which to me is a lot of you
know locker room talk."
Two years into Trump's first term as president,
the country is still divided.
There have been shocking announcements, scandals,
treaties have been torn-up - but would these
people vote for Trump again?
"Would you vote for him again?
Yes I would."
"If he runs again, I hope he wins."
"Oh I will vote for him again, I want this
to continue."
"I will vote for him again, depending on who
he's going to be running against."
At this stage, a true republican challenger
looks unlikely during the 2020 campaign, and
the Democrats will have a tall order to win
back the hearts of these voters.
Here in Julian's Brothers Bakery it seems
Trump would have no trouble getting reelected
for a second term.